يجب أن تواجه إيران تهديدًا نوويًا حقيقيًا
طالما أنني رئيسًا لوزراء إسرائيل،
وسأبذل كل ما في وسعي
لمنع إيران من الحصول على أسلحة نووية،
لكنني أعتقد
أننا على أعتاب
اختراق أكثر دراماتيكية،
وهو أمر تاريخي بين الطرفين.  إسرائيل والمملكة
العربية السعودية،
مثل هذا السلام سوف يقطع شوطا طويلا في
إنهاء الصراع العربي الإسرائيلي، وسيشجع
الدول العربية الأخرى على تطبيع
علاقاتها مع إسرائيل،
وسيعزز احتمالات السلام
مع الفلسطينيين،
وسيشجع على مصالحة أوسع
بين اليهودية والإسلام.  الإسلام بين
القدس ومكة بين
نسل إسحاق
ونسل إسماعيل
ولكن اليوم
أحمل هذه العلامة
لإظهار نعمة عظيمة،
نعمة شرق أوسط جديد
بين إسرائيل والمملكة العربية السعودية
وجيراننا الآخرين،
لن نزيل الحواجز
بين إسرائيل فقط
وسيبني جيراننا ممرًا جديدًا للسلام
والازدهار يربط آسيا
عبر الإمارات العربية المتحدة والمملكة العربية السعودية والأردن
وإسرائيل بأوروبا